sono claudia mandia e il mese scorso ho
realizzato il mio sogno ed attraverso il
mio percorso vorrei ispirarvi a
raggiungere il vostro sogno circa 18
anni fa mio fratello massimiliano ha
iniziato a praticare uno sport un po
insolito il tiro con l'arco
io vendo mio fratello come
un'ispirazione dissi voglio fare come
mio fratello massimiliano quindi io ho
iniziato con lui ho iniziato perché ha
iniziato lui è tanto che ci piacque
questo sport che iniziò anche nostra
madre mentre il nostro padre fu il
nostro sponsor per eccellenza nel 2004
mio fratello entrò a far parte della
nazionale italiana di tiro con l'arco e
io volevo riuscire ad ottenere ciò che
lui era riuscito ad ottenere
ricordo che era un caldo pomeriggio
d'agosto avevo circa 12 anni ero al
campo che mi allenavo con la mia
cuginetta daniela e la guardai negli
occhi e le dissi scommettiamo che anche
io entro in nazionale italiana di tiro
con l'arco
esattamente dieci anni fa nell'ottobre
2006 ho vinto la scommessa fu convocata
per la mia prima gara internazionale un
campionato del mondo outdoor in messico
ero la più piccola tra le più piccole
delle partecipanti così piccola ma così
piena l'orgoglio nel rappresentare la
mia nazione dall'inizio la mia ascesa
inizia e per stabilire degli obiettivi
quali appunto un campionato del mondo un
campionato europeo e insieme ad essi
iniziano nei sacrifici
ovviamente non solo miei ma anche dei
miei genitori
dopo tante gare di selezione in giro per
l'italia
dopo tante ore di allenamento e dopo
tanti incontri a roma con il mio
allenatore
capì che il mio obiettivo era cambiato
il mio non era più un obiettivo
il mio era un sogno le olimpiadi quindi
iniziai ad incrementare le ore di
allenamento iniziai a competere in più
gare
devo dirvi che il mio livello sali e
diciamo che il passaggio dalla nazionale
junior
la nazionale senior difficile per molti
per me fu cosa normale perché mi
convocarono subito i raduni con la
nazionale senior alle gare
internazionale e il mio sogno si stanno
facendo sempre più vivo finché l'anno
scorso non ho avuto un periodo difficile
proprio il periodo delle qualifiche
olimpiche mi continuavo a chiedere
perché ora forse io non ero abbastanza o
forse il mio livello si fermava un
campionato del mondo o un campionato
europeo per ora troppo basso per
competere alle olimpiadi ho pensato
anche di smettere in quel momento tutte
le decisioni che mi passavano per la
testa erano per così dire sbagliate
perché in periodi come questi è
difficile prendere delle decisioni
a meno che non pensi sia arrivato il
momento di reagire
infatti non era finita
quante volte mi gli obiettivi che mi ero
prestabilita credevo fossero più grandi
di me ma alla fine sono sempre stati
alla mia portata
sapete noi arcieri siamo un po
presuntuosi andiamo alla ricerca della
perfezione anche se essa non esiste
quando un arciere fa un nove e non un 10
significa che non ha centrato
l'obiettivo
ed è in quel momento che deve valutare
dei fattori esterni quali la luce o il
vento o dei fattori interni come un
movimento sbagliato o la perdita del
focus dopo che ha capito i propri errori
deve correggerli per centrare di nuovo
l'obiettivo il 10
e se ci pensate è così in ogni ambito
io ho imparato che per raggiungere un
obiettivo bisogna valutare tutti i
fattori interni o esterni per poi
prendere delle decisioni delle decisioni
a volte un po difficile come è capitato
a me l'anno scorso
mi sono ritrovata davanti a un bivio
scegliere di smettere o incamminarmi per
un nuovo viaggio mi sono più volte a chi
sta davanti a queste due opzioni a come
sarebbe stata la mia vita senza l'arco e
credetemi non sono mai non ho mai visto
non ho mai non mi sono mai vista senza
l'arco e quindi ho deciso di
incamminarsi per la strada della mia
passione mi sono trasferito a roma
io faccio parte del gruppo sportivo
della polizia penitenziaria le fiamme
azzurre e grazie a loro ha avuto la
disponibilità per allenarmi in delle
strutture adatte per un intero inverno
avevo tutto ciò di cui necessita un
atleta delle palestre delle strutture al
chiuso e il mio allenatore fabio con lui
ogni giorno dalla mattina fino a tarda
sera eravamo lì ad allenarci ea
controllare e materiale in ogni piccolo
particolare e spesso da salerno veniva
anche il mio preparatore atletico
antonio con lui non solo facevamo sedute
di palestra ma anche tanti test fisici e
mi sono dovuto interfaccia interfacciare
con lo psicologo perché ogni atleta a
seconda della sua mentalità del suo
carattere
deve avere un proprio metodo per
allenarsi e per competere per vincere e
per perdere ed è incredibile come
cambiando tanti piccoli fattori si
ottengono dei risultati così grandi io
non credevo di fare durante la stagione
indoor quest'anno non credevo di fare
dei punteggi talmente tanto alti tanto
dai guai a ri record del mondo 592 punti
su 600 addirittura migliorando il mio
record personale di 10 punti io non
credevo ai miei occhi ho pensato che se
ero riuscita a farla al 18 metri ero
capace di farlo anche a 70 metri la
distanza delle olimpiadi
lo scorso gennaio durante le qualifiche
interne i risultati dei miei allenamenti
furono eccelle
se in allenamento riuscivo a fare 650
660 punti su 720 io in gare a feci
addirittura quasi 680 quindi l'aver
scelto quella strada la strada della mia
passione mi ha ridato fiducia nelle mie
capacità e me stessa per arrivare lì
dove volevo arrivare lo scorso 16 giugno
ad antalya in turchia
io ero lì a conquistare le carte
olimpiche a conquistare le carte
olimpiche
io e le mie compagne di squadra
guendalina e lucilla abbiamo unito le
nostre forze abbiamo preso il posto per
il nostro sogno a cinque cerchi
le olimpiadi di rio de janeiro
inutile dirvi le urla di gioia io ho
chiamato subito i miei genitori coloro
che mi hanno spinto in questo sogno che
mi ha fatto sentire viva ho chiamato mio
fratello
io chiamo di ogni allenatore
quando ho chiamato il mio allenatore mi
sono commossa e lui mi ha detto non
piangere claudia perché siamo solo
all'inizio
io e le mie compagne guendalina e
lucilla al nostro esordio olimpico
abbiamo scritto una pagina importante
della storia della federazione italiana
di tiro con l'arco
siamo arrivate quarte a squadre mai
nessuna prima di noi era riuscito ad
arrivare così in alto
purtroppo abbiamo perso in semifinale
contro la russia facendo un 3
ma quel 3 l'abbiamo tirata e tutto
insieme così come abbiamo tirato tutti i
dieci che ci hanno portato fin li sapete
ogni atleta che partecipa alle olimpiadi
non vale solo per parteciparvi ma per
vincere e noi siamo arrivati ai piedi
del podio quindi per me questi olimpiadi
sono state solo l'inizio sono stato il
mio trampolino di lancio per un sogno
ancora più grande sapete mi hanno detto
che tokyo è una bellissima città
grazie